we talked a bit about different
monetization models in the last lesson
but let's refresh your memory with the
highlights of some of the most popular
models first there are ads serving
advertisements provide a way to make
money while you're giving your content
or app for free it's a very popular on
the web but they aren't the only model
let's see another common way to make
money there's also the one-time charge
model now in this model it's similar to
what you would experience in the real
world if you went to a brick-and-mortar
store you go to a shop pay a certain
amount to the shopkeeper and you walk
away with a t-shirt let's say now in
apps you can do this in two different
ways
first you can charge a fixed price so
the user pays a price and they can
download the app or you can charge a
price after a trial period now in both
cases there are two things that you want
to pay attention to 1 make sure that
payment is quick and easy and it doesn't
require a user to log in second use an
established payment model stripe PayPal
Google pay Apple pay what have you this
will make sure that your users have a
convenient and consistent checkout flow
the subscription model is another option
there are many cases where we wish to
sell our service on a monthly or yearly
basis the big advantage that made this
model so popular is the fact that you
get to earn more due to the increase in
the lifetime value of your users and
they feel more comfortable because in
that pay-as-you-go model they got a full
control on the expenses lastly there are
in-app payments and this is a very
popular model these days as it combines
two main user preferences free apps as
the starting point and then a way to
monetize in that user after they've
decided that your products worth it